quel est votre nom ali ghannouchi
revenir
grâce à ces nantis piani votre religion
qu'aux musulmans chiites
orthodoxe géorgienne
quel est votre voeu
[Musique]
je vous demande de nous rejoindre pour
défendre notre peuple
et empêcher l'ennemi d'entrer chez nous
[Musique]
mme accorderiez vous cette danse
je ne pense pas que tu veuilles l'épousé
disparue
[Musique]
et ça ne vous dérange pas qu'il serait
musulman
ça devrait j'ai l'honneur de demander à
son altesse la permission d'épouser
princesse nine ce qui est sûr c'est que
le monde vient de s'engager dans une
guerre alors il vaudrait mieux attendre
que tout ce film je ne veux pas aller à
moscou
tout a déjà été organisé voulez vous
conservez votre religion
on pourrait s'enfuir et quitter le pays
on se met à rêver à moscou qu'est ce que
vous faites
et fait ressortir
ils sont en train de détruire la ville
on doit partir
on va s'enfuir tous les deux
[Musique]
notre ville est cernée par des centaines
de déserteurs de l'armée du tas
maintenant
[Musique]
je vous aime lino